can you tell us how you got involved
with man in a box yeah it's actually a
pretty awesome story in and of itself
it's it's I think it's very relevant to
the times we live in so we actually got
connected through Facebook you know
through the social network and what
happened was one of the other producers
on man in a box had seen I guess they
might have been friends with my friends
band and saw a couple music videos that
I had done for him and you know they
liked the videos and they contact me on
Facebook and said hey you really liked
you know these videos we saw um you know
he tell us more about yourself and you
know kind of went from there and they
you know checked out my websites all
other editing projects that I had done
and some of our work and you know next
thing you know kevin was contacting me
and explained to me you know about man
in a box and you know what they were
looking for so it was just sort of a you
know six degrees of separation type
thing oh wow yeah yeah that's great and
then once he contacted you did you guys
actually meet in person no so I mean you
know we talked on the phone quite a bit
and I asked him to send me the script
and that I really love to read the
script and I should read the script in
two days I actually really liked the
story you know loved loved the how was
written characterisations everything and
so I said okay you know you know this
sounds like a really cool project I'd
love to get involved in it so what were
your duties your producer but what would
happen under your sort of in your area
so um well what had happened was you
know him and I discussed him bringing me
on as a creative producer because there
was a lot of stuff that he him and I
talked about about reshoots and you know
he was one thing that was really great
in our discussions was that I was
concerned about you know a film they say
a film has made three times it's made
first by the writer and second by the
director and the production team then
third by the editor arm and when you
when you come into something you know as
the outsider
as a freelance editor um you know where
you weren't part of the process in the
very beginning stage you know you the
question for me is always well what does
this director wat you know like how much
control am I going to have as a story
telling myself to reshape things you
know based on what they filmed based on
what their original vision was and he
was very open to like so many my
suggestions which was which was so great
that was so rewarding as an editor to be
able to work with somebody who was like
hey you know I really value your your
input so how would you want to do this
and that's where it kind of stemmed into
me becoming you know a producer on the
film as creative was you know through
you know going over the script going to
the footage and me kind of you know
seeing opportunities that there were
spots that we could have done a little
bit better and I asked him I said is
there an opportunity you know how you
know that we could refill things you
know can you talk to the actors and he
and he did and that was I mean that was
amazing to me you know was that he he
said you know what let me make some
calls and he got a bunch of the actors
and you know from there you know him and
I discussed it and you know I helped him
storyboards and stuff so that we would
get exactly what we wanted to make you
know these retakes these scenes you know
as best as they could be so
you